here's what we're trying to do we're
trying to make strangers feel something
at the same time if you talk to a
production designer and they're good
they're not talking to you about oh my
God you have any idea how many people
it's going to take to come in here and
you know how many we got to lay all the
subfloor we got to do this you know we
got how much pain it's going to take
they're not talking to you about that
they're talking to you about the feeling
they're talking to you about the thing
that you want to evoke you know when
you're talking to Trent resner and
Atticus Ross you're not talking about
use this synthesizer or this drum
machine or whatever you're talking about
I need a feeling Happening Here I want
your version of the kind of music that
they play when you get a massage you
know it's always supposed to be this
music that kind of calms you and lets
you know everything's going to be okay
give that to Trent resner and Atticus
Ross and see what they come back with
and and you end up with something that
makes you go you know it sounds like it
just sounds like the hair standing up in
the back of your neck but it still has
this idea behind it because the idea is
the important thing